Little bit other thought it more airstrikes more bombs and
more casualties
it is not
letting up we had a soft I don't know I
thought he wouldn't
Across the eastern ghouta rescue
workers Sprint into broken
and burning buildings before the dust of
their destruction circles
my village.
This was another attack a few miles away a temporary
cease fire is under negotiation brokered by Russia Egypt and
Turkey.
it happens is the horror of these days
we'll stay with the
survivors for a lifetime.
a lot H Dayton or 11 were in their home
when I hope well more players bombeat I will not
be feeling.
So it
Look at home.
This was sent to us by their mother shamsul.
Please help us please
set on here in is good word is the humidity.
I asked him instead of mother.
Please help us.
I'm getting on for 400,000 people terrified by the sight
and sound of aircraft I thought to be in eastern
ghouta which is the size of Manchester.
The Syrian regime insists it's targeting terrorists but it's clear
many children are among the woon did and the dead.
Improvised hospitals have been set up in Cellars in basements
during the years of war.
Various not now though the medics are at full stretch.
money by law wanted to send a message to
the people
of Britain.
Set up waiting on time we never wanted the war
and we don't want to live under it for the
sake of our children have been blown to pieces for
the sake of our children who died of hunger what
we're seeing every day has caused us to collapse.
Both humanely and psychologically we don't have anything more to
offer were being bled out.
Doctor and many was treating 12 year old Mohammed he
was dying.
His mother will mark mark had been cooking breakfast for
her family when 3 S traits came in.
I'm here waiting for my son to die at least
he'll be free of pain I pray to God to
end his suffering but where are the Arabs where are
the Muslims do we have to appeal to Israel.
We my boy dies he'll go to heaven or at
least ill be able to eat I'd like to die
with him so I can look after him.
Syrians have cried so many tears in the last 7
years of war the killing is escalating not ending and
once again the world is watching.
From a safe distance. Jeremy bohen BBC news.